a vigil for british journalists dom
phillips and indigenous expert bruno
pereira
family friends and colleagues of the
pair gathered in rio de janeiro
demanding to know what's happened to
them
they went missing a week ago in the
javari valley an area in the amazon
twice the size of japan and home to the
largest number of uncontacted tribes in
the world
the vigil was held on capacabana beach
the place where phillips used to paddle
surf before moving to northeastern
brazil to write a book about saving the
amazon
he was on his way back from an
expedition with pedera when both men
disappeared
human remains were reportedly found
where the pair was last seen but they
are still being identified
this was dom's last trip there he told
my sister his wife alessandra that he
needed one more interview to finish his
book i think dom went to the amazon
because he belonged there he's an
english man who was born in the wrong
place he loved the rainforest and their
inhabitants
pereira used to work for funai the
government agency responsible for
protecting brazil's indigenous people
bruno was forced to leave the agency
because he did not agree with president
j bolsonaro's policy of opening up the
amazon for commercial exploitation and
leaving it unprotected
there are only 1400 people in our agency
and we have to protect one million
indigenous people occupying an area that
represents 13 percent of brazil's
territory
pereira started working on his own with
the javadi tribes we accompanied him
during an expedition several months ago
in the same area where he was last seen
with dom phillips pereira was already
being threatened because he was helping
local tribes collect evidence of the
invasions to their territories and
report them to local authorities
at first we were very hopeful that both
men were alive because dom was with
bruno who is very experienced the family
thought they must have been ambushed but
managed to hide the boat and escape
through the forest but our week has gone
by and our hopes are diminishing all we
want now is for them to be found we have
a right to know what happened to them
this march is not only to put pressure
on the government to find writer don
phillips and indigenous expert bruno
pereira it's also for a bigger cause
people here say
both men defended saving the amazon
monica yanakiv al jazeera rio de janeiro